[Musique]
koné lino c'est donc jean michel lemaire
contre eux géraldine ou là jean michel
mr géraldine alors attention attention
vous devez trouver à lapins dorés
données l'amener là non mais à mon top
non mais eksi d'allô prof fait une tête
de cul non mais ne riez pas une course
folle cherché à la vendre mais qui
trouve le lapin doré prend le salaire de
l'autre attention c'est parti
top à 10 go trouvait déjà dans l apard
doré qui les coûts à la page aurait des
médias des trucs pareils
vous pouvez les suivre il ya un truc non
ils ont une chair c'est gagner moselle
bravo il offre à dire à votre iphone et
vous mettre en place a les yeux alors
vous devez chanter je crois que j'avais
sûreté chaud cacao d'annie cordy way red
bank est une question de génération vous
allez devoir et d'en prendre une
cuillère de chocolat en poudre
chaque toutes les sacs jaunes je vous la
donnerais d'accord moi j'ai horreur du
chocolat baye fall alors maréchal et
donc ils sont jaunes à cause du café
vous êtes vraiment ensemble vous m'aimez
vous
[Musique]
enfin amener d'autres comme les cherry
pour donner la réponse à chaque fois
faudra faire la même chose d'accord up
attention que du succès 6 4 mais ne
mangez pas ça au québec
non mais vous allez y énorme problème
avec shire est un supporter attention
trois deux un top faut trois à la
penderie à lapins dorés attention
attention talent jusqu'à ce que tu as le
tas n'a pas dix mois oui mais j'étais
dazhou arrière il a proposé des
chocolats toute l'équipe et la bdi avec
valve ou mais il avait des poudres non
non non c'est pas dans ses pas mais
c'est bien là l'enjeu reconnaît aussi
non non non c'est pas moins brésilien de
l'as roma le rédac'chef thibault dit
[ __ ] je bouffe au chocolat
[Applaudissements]
les kiwis chocolat
[Musique]
cyril en chocolat une raquette de vue
une bombe ont l'un et de petites boules
depuis mai à deux balles merci m
faustin kouassi l'a compris que je sais
c'est ccc compris que son plein tu veux
que je te continue j'ai compris que je
vais manger des boules à l'autre et à
[Applaudissements]
halle au salé vous êtes le meilleur là
dedans jean-luc le fait très bien
on n'est pas trop qpc barton mais c'est
quoi ce délire
c'est quoi le délire allez-y c'est allé
vite votre vers la fin dont le premier
qui trouve le lap adoré repart avec le
salaire de l'autre à ça ça m'intéresse
ah bah oui surtout castaldi et oui on
marche mais ça chauffe la bataille
[Rires]
v
thomas howell an plus tôt or avant
d'essuyer alors
[Musique]
si tu me donnes des noix de coco moi je
te donne mes bandages cacao
[Musique]
chocolat vite dissipée dit titi je vomis
pour tout le public ce soir parce que
vous êtes venu tout à fait déplacé que
vous n'êtes pas payé
eh bien les séries je vous offre grâce à
un ami il s'appelle jeff et qu'habite
bruges
[Rires]
sachez sachez que c'est un pote de
l'eonia grecs également et qu'il a une
très belle maison là une maison du
chocolat au lait fairebel travaux
quelques grammes de finesse dans un
monde de brutes tunnel talent que vous
offre du chocolat à tous et pour eux et
nous est il celui qui trouve le napa
doré gagne le salaire de l'autre allez-y
non non non non la vous ayez 3,7 à 3,3
non non non non c'est froid
non jean-luc reste plutôt à gauche mais
ces deux malades
allez-y vite vite vite vite il m'a dit
ce beau temps non c'est froid là c'est
fois c'est pas cher
il ya plein de chocolat mais non les
mecs galop c'est le seul gars qui
sauvent avec des fleurs et on n'y va pas
lui c'est direct
[Musique]
[Rires]